okay so so this is lucy this is lily i'm
chris hi should we say our own names i
feel like we should say our own like a
pokemon just
listen lucy and i are trying to find a
man for lily i feel like you can tell a
lot about a guy just based on his google
search history even more than you can
just by talking to him so today we're
gonna go through the search histories of
three different single guys you're gonna
try to figure out what they're like and
decide which one you want to go on a
date with sound good sounds good cool
hi i'm marco hi i'm darren hi i'm haru
marco i saw that you had a good amount
of fashion searches it's just like one
of the ways i like to express myself and
it is i would say maybe something i look
for in somebody like what kind of a guy
are you looking for and what do you
think he searches for on google there's
something called the 6666 it stands for
six feet
six figures six pack and at least a six
in personality
so yeah six out of ten six out of ten
your ideal guy what do you think is
gonna be in his surgery i think like
that they have interesting hobbies i
think they'll see that i have hobbies i
have things i like to do if someone has
the same interest then that's perfect
what's an interesting hobby like
anything sports related i feel like
sports will show that they work out they
prioritize taking care of their body
yeah which is like 50 of how you look
like what's the other 50
the bank statement
i saw the jujutsu kaizen oh yeah it's a
big plus if shoddy can come with me to
the theaters and watch it and sub not
dub say dub coming after you as a heads
up i didn't tell them who you are so
this is blind both ways i've never seen
them i think it's based on whatever
they're interested in because i think
all of our searches are pretty different
right now anything else anything else
you want to say before we before we get
started just the 666 6.
okay
this guy searched up nba scores i like
this okay this is good this is a good
sign this is a green flag typical it
means they play sports or maybe he's
like betting on sports
he's got money to blow yeah exactly he's
got money to blow or he's he's gambling
with all 50 of his 50 dollars dude he
either has six figures he's six foot
tall if he plays basketball oh that's a
good point maybe he has a six pack
because oh wait that's already two of
our sixes do we even need the rest of
the search
reach to surf in new york oh wait this
is he's really athletic oh my god
but then he has so much free time that
means i have no money
then he's not making six figures
[Laughter]
people with six figures never surf you
are so right also he's clueless because
he doesn't realize new york you're not
you're not surfing in new york yeah i
was surprised
okay so oh
it means he's an idiot because it's too
cold
okay this guy searched up
a chinese restaurant yeah so let's make
a recipe so if he took you there would
you be impressed um if he pays yes
i don't make six figures though right
daylight savings it means he's very on
top of his schedule like he knows you
know the dates he'll be on time i feel
like pomeranian lifestyle so he likes
dogs okay green flies we like everything
we're seeing so okay i'm thinking about
adopting a dog right that my family
friend's giving away but the pomeranian
is nine years old already
that's why i'm searching it up i used to
have three dogs okay does melatonin give
nightmares so he's a night owl that
means he has a serious um insomnia you
got insomnia is that serious it's just
hard to fall asleep sometimes i think
maybe he just has trouble sleeping and
he wants like nightmares does melatonin
give nightmares yeah he's just like a
precautionary thing okay okay i feel
like he's very health conscious he
sleeps late he probably sleeps because
he's too busy uh he's too busy making
six figures i'm in the lab that's why
the first thing i get is he's very into
sports he serves this is a great
candidate pretty wholesome really nice
sporty yeah they're all good things this
is so nice
i didn't expect that wait you guys have
to cut out the idiot don't put that in
guy number two you ready to get started
yes okay laser acne scar removal near me
okay so he's taking care of his skin i
like that yeah green flag oh my gosh say
sushi new york city okay he's gonna take
you to omakasa okay great fantastic but
you have to pay what are you gonna pay
do you like sushi yeah who doesn't like
something that's a great first date
right great first date max out his
credit card all you bro
yeah yeah
u.s shoe size to french does that mean
he likes to travel or he's from france
kanye pete davidson memes it shows that
he's like funny he like he's they're so
false yeah they're like they're turning
everything into a good thing i think
this guy seems more wealthy
he kind of cares about his image yeah
laser acne that's like expensive it's
like 50 bucks 70 dollars
speak easy's new york city okay so he
likes to go out get hammered black out i
feel like this guy probably wait i feel
like speakeasy is kind of like a classy
vibe oh it's classy yeah louis vuitton
men's what does rtw stand for 2022
that's ready to wear wait he is so into
fashion he's into fashion wait he
definitely has a good sense of style
maybe he's from europe are you
originally from here
are you from here honey you should say
i'm yeah i'm from pittsburgh she thought
i was from cali she thinks you're from
europe she don't think you're from korea
i'm a boy he likes travel what if he has
an accent
okay okay he's looking at prada orange
sunglasses if you wear orange sunglasses
you're like a hipster i've already the
black ones i gotta get those yeah he's
very like he wears like orange
sunglasses
i feel like i would only wear that on
halloween wait till they see your jacket
i feel like you appreciate someone with
like financial freedom but i don't know
how much you care about for example like
designer
that's a good point shrek memes
okay this guy definitely seems like he's
like that's a curveball like a home body
like he like on a friday night he would
stay home and look at me
he was also looking at speakeasies yeah
get a man that can do both get a man
that can do both shrek
shrek is very internet you think so it's
very uh deep fried dank memes internet
type humor you know what i mean no i
don't know i don't think i'm not i'm not
connecting with this person i don't know
i'm not vibing yeah i feel like i
watched like when i was like there's a
lot of like flashy searches that were
like kind of cool but mo hair sweater
black large she's a large large there we
go that means he's tall okay that's the
six six out of the six feet he's at
least large how tall is he he's
definitely like living a very luxurious
life and he's very fashionable to the
point where it's like it's a little much
you know some days i just want to wear
sweatpants i don't know if he's okay
with that i can get down with weapons
good mood is that a song it is a song
new york soul singer producer seoul is
in korea oh so he's korean he's korean
i'm not korean you're not i'm not korean
oh yeah you're not cause like i've never
heard of this yeah i've never heard of
so he's like really into
like learning about new music are you i
just listen to what's on the radio the
radio maybe he creates music
music
18
pikachu funko pop is that muscle music
is this music is this music
18 inch don't know who pikachu is dasai
45 is that a wrestler is that another
artist sake it looks like a sake oh so
he he has very particular taste like
we're just not cultured yeah i'm down to
taste new alcohol i got you difference
between pan pizza and hand tossed pizza
wait so he cooks or he's trying to order
pizza and they have two different
sections on the menu and he has no clue
what the difference is i'm just waiting
to be called an idiot as well green flag
green flag yes
oh my god that's a great restaurant it's
um it's a korean restaurant he's
definitely i mean i guess anyone can go
to rib number seven but maru okay
tomorrow karaoke a k-town regular i see
i worked there okay so have you been
tomorrow i think i did you have don't
lie oh what is that
it's an anime okay okay so you don't
watch anime yeah i don't watch anime but
i don't think i i
tft syndra re-roll is that something you
do
okay i have nothing in common this
sounds like another game yeah you have
you really don't oh no it's team fight
tactics yeah you have nothing i have
nothing in common but chris just gonna
pretend he doesn't know league
so number three is probably the third
least likely yeah he seems like a very
fun person but we just don't have a lot
in common and he would be a great person
to hang out with but not someone i would
date the second guy seems very put
together cares about his appearance
which is great but i feel like i am not
at that level but he seems fun like he's
going to speak easy he's looking at his
travels yeah i think he will be a really
fun friend they will be a better match
for each other
that's crazy but i think option one he's
more into sports i love you know working
out i think that's really important
he seems more wholesome doesn't have a
lot of alcohol related searches so yeah
i think i would choose option one this
is gonna be crazy awesome you ready to
meet him sure
i'm so excited
hey guys
i think what we need is a group hug
group hug group hug guys
oh my god they hate us
i'm scared well you guys seem really mad
i apologize in advance
i thought you were pretty nice based on
what you were about i was like oh you're
nicer tonight yeah so who
i'll just say you picked dan right dan
i knew it he doesn't he doesn't seem
very happy i'm okay with it
he's got some concerns oh yeah i just i
i i got i got a few concerns all right
wow this is tense okay
i don't know what to do anymore
okay so um
oh sorry [ __ ]
gotta pay the meter with my less than
six figure salary
all right this whole like swipe his
credit card thing like and also what's
wrong with the color orange
like he's googling orange product
sunglasses nothing's wrong with that
those number one orange no like if my
jacket's orange is cool
no
[Laughter]
so are you from california no i was born
and raised here oh you were yeah
yeah but people could surf here you know
that yeah
yeah you said i was an idiot for
searching that too
so you be going to the gym yes do you go
to the gym
sometime how how often
like three four times a week oh that's
good
that's really good
am i going to have to pay for your
membership though if we go
no you don't i'll pay for your
membership oh you're going to pay for my
membership yeah yo guys
she's going to pay for me let's go
[Applause]
i'm just i'm just defending my guy i
feel like i'm like starting to sweat
just sitting right i'm sorry
so
guys so we're gonna actually cut for a
sec we'll just chill for a bit you guys
can go off on your own little mini date
and then we can check in afterwards and
see what you guys want to do after that
does that sound good
yeah we're getting a divorce
[Music]
lily dan how many kids you having i told
her zero i gave her my reasons he wants
to focus on himself uh you sound very
stressed right now
but a dog you'll have a dog of course
yeah yeah yeah yeah so did anything
surprise you no
i didn't think you would have like 10
000 tattoos what's wrong with tattoos
nothing's wrong with tattoos i i he i
think i i think you definitely i don't
i'm not confused
um you seem very athletic like you go to
the gym so i mean if he flexes the
tattoo arm you can flex your tattoo arm
that's my smaller arm though
any of you guys have an idea for how to
end this video
but you have to give a reason why though
if we're going to end up
just kidding
we should just end it as
friendship friendship
really nailed that
it was friendship right you guys heard
friendship we're all right
you heard friendship well let's do a
group hug
you had a friendship a day do you heard
friendship let's do like we should end
it with a group hug everyone all right
group hug
okay
we need to pie a lot okay group hug all
right
okay
friendship
i love you all as friends
okay oh man it's hurt so you're paying
for the whole thing i'll pay